news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so this next story started to develop
last night and i
i have to tell you i can't wait i am
really like a kid on christmas morning
and yeah
i'm jewish but the metaphor just works
like a kid on christmas morning
waiting for video to be released because
donald trump yesterday was interviewed
for an upcoming episode of 60 minutes
and we've learned
that in the middle of the interview
trump abruptly and furiously got up and
left ending the interview with 60
minutes correspondent leslie stahl
and then started tweeting ridiculous
things about the interview
you this has to be seen to be believed
the reporting
is that in the interview trump became
frustrated
with the questions that leslie stahl was
asking that tracks perfectly with
trump's displeasure
at being asked real questions and in
particular in situations where he can't
weasel his way out
the example from last week's town hall
where savannah guthrie
actually pressed trump about his obvious
lies
as to when was he tested was he tested
for coronavirus before the debate and
trump just obviously lying and being
dishonest
and trump lost it on savannah guthrie
saying she was terrible horrible all
this stuff
same thing happened with 60 minutes
after about 45 minutes of this 60
minutes interview
trump gets up and leaves and just
doesn't come back but he was
highly highly triggered first trump
tweeted a video
of the interviewer leslie stahl not
wearing a mask at the white house as an
attack on her
we later learned that this was just
moments after trump abruptly
left the interview and leslie stahl of
course being on camera had removed her
mask
and she was talking to producers about
like it's trump coming back or
is this over she hadn't yet put her mask
on trump attacking her for that that's
already weird
but then trump bizarrely tweeting about
the interview itself that quote
i am pleased to inform you that for the
sake of accuracy in reporting
i am considering posting my interview
with leslie stahl of 60 minutes
prior to air time this will be done so
that everybody can get a glimpse of what
a fake and biased interview is all about
everyone should compare this terrible
electoral intrusion
with the recent interviews of sleepy joe
biden so i guess the implication is
maybe trump has the raw video of the
entire interview
or maybe trump's just lying who the hell
knows but apparently a reporter asking
real questions
is considered an intrusion on the
electoral process now
per donald trump this is a joke guys we
are a joke
the country is a joke this man is a joke
it really can't continue and in normal
situations
a president being unable to handle a 60
minutes interview
walking out it would be a national
scandal if barack obama had done this
uh it would be 24 7 on right-wing news
saying
the president can't handle it what an
embarrassment he can't stand the heat
if he can't stand up to leslie stahl how
can he stand up to she and putin and kim
jong right
all that stuff if it had been obama with
trump
trump has so weaponized his followers
against the media
in a dystopian act of hostility that the
trumpists are furious if you look
at the places online where the trump is
hanging out the trumpists are furious
with leslie stahl and with 60 minutes
but what we can be sure of
is that if trump walked out the
interview must have been really bad
because even interviews that you and i
recognize as having gone badly for
donald trump trump thinks he did well
so if even trump thinks he didn't do
well in the interview
it must be a complete disaster if trump
flees the interview
and starts slamming the interviewer on
twitter
you know it went really really bad and i
hope that this is released
a sunday very much looking forward to it